hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Veronica
success I'm Marie and tonight and we're
gonna watch the trailer for Tammy stars
Melissa McCarthy girls okay
do you know that yes yes yes kind of
know the large funny woman huh oh you
mean the family she's the person that
plays characters whose entire existence
is just fat jokes yeah yeah exactly that
that is very very funny she's very she's
very good at playing fat boy yeah yeah
yeah worked her way up paper way up you
know I mean would you here we go I'm
sure it's gonna be more obnoxious
matchups but whatever this song female
please move yes please Billy we're kind
of getting somewhere and I'm in
different circumstance you know good
pals like to find like a hot tub I
actually have an apartment complex
fingers crossed we we meet up again this
is Robbie I don't know where I'm going
I've always wanted to go to Niagara
Falls how about a beer Oh
listy no oh my god you're pregnant
I'm driving a car you're fugitive from
justice
just throw the money through the window
and we can
what have you ever done that's that cool
I watched Neil Armstrong walk his bite
just like a beautiful portrait of like
American white trash
yeah it looks trashy that's wasn't safe
did you guys notice that in one scene
she was wearing the uniform of the fast
food restaurant no what does that mean
oh my god it's it's cheaper than just a
comedy Murray you're onto something I'm
onto something I'm lost I don't know
what's happening she never does she
never does yeah okay well thanks cash
it's not about that trailer does look
really funny and Melissa McCarthy stay
overweight I like what you're doing but
I'm concerned for your health if you
knew the channel why'd you subscribe
hanging with hot girls like this one
come on but even sexier male specimen
scribe do it every day yeah do it best
thing I did I really like my friends but
here is I've been waiting to shut this
guy out just because I don't get why he
said this to me shout him out Jay vonlee
you called me a rapist I don't know why
I have done nothing along the lines of
what you are accusing you
it is harsh I don't even want to make
jokes about it that's not just serving
topic too soon too soon for me later
joke's on this channel you need to build
up credibility before you cover that
we're moving on from you buddy sorry
shoutout but I can't stay on this topic
pretty long Julianne xyn burger I'm
assuming you're Jewish based off your
last name which is awesome but I like
the Lord Jesus
so we're at a difference my friend what
are we gonna do what are we gonna do
don't know Mormon she's probably one I
mean days Mormon and German are not
mutually exclusive do you want to see
here really an accident burger maybe
you're Jewish maybe a German doesn't
matter we can put aside our races and
our beliefs for a second here so I could
give you this shadow amen
I'm Nam an almond or well hi umm
whatever that was anything I don't think
that's correct
hmm sure ain't about Judaism arc of arcs
cool name like it like mark of ours want
to shout out by imagining a massive boat
with several smaller but still gigantic
boats inside of it so what you are we
have to destroy this boat before it
takes over